you
in my last video I post the following
question if you take n points on a
circle then connect every pair of them
with a line how many sections do these
lines cut the circle into what was
strange is that when n is less than 6
and when n is 10 for some reason the
answer is always a power of 2 but for
all other values of n the answer seems
completely unrelated to powers of 2 what
I love about this problem is that it
brings together many disparate concepts
counting functions graphs one of Euler's
most famous equations and Pascal's
triangle you might be wondering if
changing the placement of points changes
the number of sections
it actually can for instance watch how
the small region in the middle
disappears if we adjust things so that
three lines go through the same point
but if we add the restriction that no
three lines can go through the same
point the number of sections depends
only on the number of points not their
placement as you're about to see I think
it's fair to call this a hard problem
and in solving hard problems it's a good
idea to ask simpler questions about the
same set up in this case I have two
questions for you one how many lines are
there and two at how many points do
these lines intersect within the circle
for the first question every line
corresponds uniquely with a pair of
points and likewise every pair of points
gives us a unique line luckily Counting
the number of pairs in a set is common
enough in math that we have specific
notation for it and choose to which we
evaluate as n times n minus 1 divided by
2 to see where this formula comes from
notice that you have n options for the
first element of the pair which we
multiply by the N minus 1 remaining
options for the second element but this
would double count each pair so we
divide by 2
for instance when N equals 7/7 choose 2
is 7 times 6 over 2 or 21 so there are
21 pairs of points and hence 21 lines
with say a hundred points
counting lines directly would be a
nightmare but we can compute it as 100
choose 2 which is 100 times 99 divided
by 2 or 4950 the number of intersection
points is a bit more subtle while every
intersection point corresponds with a
unique pair of lines there are many
pairs of lines that don't intersect
within the circle so we can't just count
the pairs of lines what we can do though
is associate each intersection point
with a set of 4 points on the circle
since this Association goes the other
way around in that every quadruplet of
points gives a unique intersection point
let's look at that isn't that elegant
this means the number of intersection
points is the same as the number of
quadruplets of our end starting points
the function n choose 4 counts
quadruplets in a set of size N and you
evaluate it by taking n times n minus 1
times n minus 2 times n minus 3 all
divided by 1 times 2 times 3 times 4 the
derivation of this formula is similar to
that of n choose 2 you multiply in the
number of options you have for each
successive entry then divide by the
extent to which you've over counted
for instance with any +4 4 choose 4 is 1
and indeed there's just one intersection
point 6 choose 4 is 15 so when n equal 6
there are 15 intersection points and if
n were 100 even though the prospect of
counting intersection points is
horrifying
we can nevertheless deduce that there
will be 3 million nine hundred twenty
one thousand two hundred twenty five of
them now how does this help us count
sections in the circle you might ask
well it will once we consider graphs and
Euler's formula no one home not function
graphs and not that e to the PI stuff
the word graph can also refer to a set
of points referred to as vertices along
with a set of lines connecting some of
these points which we call edges notice
if we count the number of vertices in
this graph then subtract the number of
edges then add the number of regions
that this graph cuts space into along
with that outer region we get to if we
do the same thing with this other graph
well we get to again
this isn't a coincidence you could do
this with any graph and as long as your
edges don't intersect each other the
answer is always two if edges could
intersect then you could just change the
number of regions without changing them
for vertices and edges so of course it
would be nonsense this relation is known
as Euler's characteristic formula and
it's easy to see where the name comes
from since Euler's is German for
beautiful if you're curious the reason
we write F for the number of regions is
because the formula traditionally refers
to the number of vertices edges and
faces of 3d polyhedron in another video
I'll explain why this is true but here
let's just use it to solve our circle
problem our set up is already a graph
with n vertices and n choose two edges
one between each pair of points but we
cannot apply Euler's characteristic
formula directly since our edges
intersect many times and choose four
times to be exact however if we consider
each intersection point to be a vertex
meaning our original lines must be
chopped up at these points and if we
also include the segments of the circle
connecting our n outer points as new
edges we have a graph perfectly suited
for Euler's formula in particular the
number of regions in this picture is the
number of edges in our new graph minus
the number of vertices plus two since
our new graph retains the an original
vertices and adds on another n choose
four for intersection points we replace
the minus V term with minus n minus n
choose four to find the number of edges
note that the intersection points can be
seen as adding two edges each as each
one takes two existing lines and then
cuts them into four smaller pieces for
example three lines intersecting at two
points would be cut into three plus two
times two equals seven smaller pieces
for lines intersecting at three points
would be cut into four plus two times
three equals ten smaller pieces and in
our circle diagram our n choose two
lines intersecting at n choose four
points are cutting to n choose two plus
two times n choose four smaller pieces
plus another end for the circle segments
we're now considering to be edges going
back to our formula we can replace e
with n choose two plus two times n
choose 4 plus n combining like terms we
our graph cuts the 2d plane into 2 plus
n choose 2 plus n choose 4 pieces since
we're concerned with counting the
regions inside the circle we can
disregard that outer region and write
our final answer is 1 plus n choose 2
plus n choose 4 great we found the
answer but why on earth is this formula
relate to powers of 2 for n less than 6
then again when N equals 10 it's not
just a coincidence it has to do with
Pascal's triangle Pascal's triangle is
constructed like this each term is the
sum of the two terms above it if you add
up each row you get a successive power
of 2 to convince yourself of this notice
that each term is added into the
following row twice so the sum of each
row should be twice the sum of the row
before it the function n choose K is
closely related to this triangle in that
the cape entry of the nth row we're
counting starts at 0 is always n choose
K for instance to find 5 to 3 in the
triangle countdown to the 0 1 2 3 4
fifth row then go in 0 1 2 3 and indeed
5 choose 3 equals 10 this means that the
answer to our circle problem for
endpoints is the sum of the 0th 2nd and
4th entries of the nth row of Pascal's
triangle
for instance if N equals 5 we can see
that we just have to add 1 10 and 5
since each term is the sum of the two
above it this is the same as adding the
entire fourth row which we know is a
power of 2 likewise for smaller values
of n the answer is going to be the sum
of the N minus first row that hits a
power of 2 however when N equals 6 and
we relate the terms to the fifth row
notice that we're not adding the entire
row hence we miss that last term so we
only get 31 when N equals 10 were
summing precisely half of the ninth row
so the answer is 1/2 of 2 to the 9th
which is true today
so to recap first turn our diagram into
a graph suitable for Euler's
characteristic formula by adding all of
the intersection points as vertices and
cutting up all the edges next count the
number of lines and intersection points
by relating them to pairs and
quadruplets of our starting points
and finally use Euler's formula to
deduce the number of sections and then
relate this to powers of two using
Pascal's triangle